How do you communicate authentically?
How do you figure out what to say and what not to say in a way that's authentic?
And what Fred says, and I really believe this is true,...
...is it starts from the fundamental understanding that there is no truth:...
...There's my truth, there's your truth,...
...and everything is subjective.
And so, if you always start from the position of "This is what I believe;"...
..."I don't expect you to believe it;"...
..."I don't think you have to believe it;"...
..."I'm not saying it's true;"...
...you can actually always communicate authentically.
'Cause if you walk in the room, and this gets worse as you get more senior,...
..."Here's the answer:" you're not giving anyone else any room to say anything.
And if you walk in the room and say,...
"I believe this for this reason."
"What do you believe?"
If you share your truth in that language, you give people room to authenticate,...
...to communicate authentically.
And that is hugely important to these relationships at any stage.